[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen guten Abend wünsche ich
Ihnen und herzlich willkommen unter
anderem Fußball hat Sven Voss für Sie
auch von mir schönen guten Abend schauen
wir unsere Themen
die Ampel und das Cannabis Freigabe ja
aber nur für den Eigenanbau die
geplanten Regeln sind kompliziert
was tun gegen übervolle Notaufnahmen der
Vorsitzende der Kassenärztlichen
Bundesvereinigung will eine Strafgebühr
und erhält viel Widerspruch
und war es das schon die Bayern gehen in
Manchester unter und brauchen ein
Fußballwunder in Champions League
Rückspiel
Cannabis soll noch in diesem Jahr
legalisiert werden allerdings nur
teilweise es ist ein Kernprojekt der
Ampel-Koalition
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach musste
aber seine umfassenderen Pläne
Eindampfen sie verstießen gegen EU Recht
heute stellte Lauterbach zusammen mit
Agrarminister Özdemir die Eckpunkte für
ein Gesetzentwurf vor und so sehen sie
aus
der Besitz von 25 Gramm zum Eigenkonsum
soll künftig straffrei sein außerdem
darf jeder für den privaten Konsum drei
Pflanzen anbauen
spezielle Clubs sollen Cannabis für ihre
Mitglieder produzieren dürfen das alles
gilt nur für Erwachsene in Deutschland
hat 2021 jeder elfte der 18 bis
64-Jährigen mindestens einmal die Droge
konsumiert Andrea Maurer zu den Plänen
und Risiken
Ibbenbüren Nordrhein-Westfalen hier wo
heute Hortensien gezüchtet werden könnte
schon bald Cannabis wachsen dem Spieker
will gemeinsam mit Partnern den Vertrieb
aufbauen für einen legalen Konsum wir
möchten ganz gerne diesen Markt sicher
machen und vor allen Dingen
nachvollziehbar machen gerade was
thc-gehalte betrifft und Jugendschutz
auch der Gesundheitsminister hält die
bisherige cannabiskontrollpolitik für
gescheitert und stellt heute seine
überarbeiteten Gesetzespläne vor wir
wollen die Jugend besser schützen wir
wollen den Schwarzmarkt bekämpfen wir
wollen den die Drogen Kriminalität
zurückdrängen wie wollen die stetig
zunehmende Toxizität der Produkte wollen
wir in den Griff bekommen eine Abgabe in
lizenzierten Geschäften und Apotheken
aber wie im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
wird es vorerst nicht geben die Pläne
sind unvereinbar mit EU-Recht wonach
Schengen Staaten den Verkauf von
Cannabis unterbinden müssen vielmehr
sollen nun ab Sommer nur in wenigen
Modellregionen eine Abgabe fünf Jahre
erprobt werden die CSU befürchtet
drogenturismus und zweifelt an der
Rechtmäßigkeit man will ja
Modellregionen mit wissenschaftlicher
Begleitung machen um nachher Cannabis
als Genussmittel weit auszurollen und zu
verbreiten das ist aus meiner Sicht
rechtlich nicht zulässig auch wenn eine
Abgabe erst ab 18 Jahren erlaubt sein
soll warnen Kinderärzte vor einer
Verharmlosung der Droge die Gefahren
sind weiterhin natürlich gerade für
junge Erwachsene Jugendliche und Kinder
das eben das Gehirn noch nicht
ausreichend und endgültig vernetzt ist
und hier liegt der Gefahrenpunkt hier
setzt das THC an und sorgt dafür dass
Kinder und Jugendliche vor allem
eben jünger sie sind desto häufiger zu
Psychosen neigen im April soll ein
erster Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt werden an
den Eckpunkten des Ministers könnte sich
im Gesetzgebungsverfahren noch einiges
ändern
was steckt eigentlich in Cannabis und
wie wirkt es im menschlichen Körper
antworten darauf gibt es in der ZDF
heute App dort können Sie sich mit einer
interaktiven 3D-Grafik selbst über die
Pflanze informieren
immer wieder sind Notaufnahmen von
Krankenhäusern überlastet weil auch
viele Menschen mit bagatellproblemen
kommen jetzt fordert der Verbandschef
der Kassenärzte Gassen eine Gebühr für
Patienten und Patientinnen die ohne
telefonische Ersteinschätzung zur
Notaufnahme gehen
eigentlich soll es so laufen wenn die
hausärztliche Praxis geschlossen ist
gibt es noch die Bereitschaftsdienste
die Notaufnahmen sind für
lebensbedrohliche Fälle zuständig oder
wenn bleibende Schäden drohen mehr von
Christel Haas
überfüllte Warteräume und Flure
stundenlanges Warten gestresste Ärzte
das ist oft Alltag in den Notaufnahmen
auch weil viele die kommen keine echten
Notfälle sind unsozial nennt das der
kassenärztechef eine extra-gebührnisse
her für alle die ohne telefonische
ärztliche Einschätzung in die
Notaufnahmen kommen
es ist auf Dauer nicht durchführbar dass
jeder gemäß eigene Einschätzung sich zum
Notfall erklärt und dann auch zu uns
Zeiten verschiedene Bereiche des
Bereitschaftsdienst oder des Notdienstes
adressiert ein Vorschlag von dem der
Gesundheitsminister und auch
Notfallärzte nicht viel halten das ist
ein falsches Signal für den Patienten
der ja Hilfe suchen sich an die
Notaufnahme wendet gesetz den Fall er
hat Sorge davor dass er eine Gebühr
bezahlen muss und wendet sich vielleicht
nicht mit einer beispielsweise
lebensbedrohlichen Erkrankung an die
Notaufnahme und geht wieder nach Hause
oder geht gar keinem Arzt dann wäre das
eventuell katastrophal für den Patienten
dazu kommt viele die zuerst beim
ärztlichen Notdienst anrufen bleiben in
der Warteschleife hängen und gehen dann
doch in die Notaufnahme
am Mainzer Uniklinikum glaubt man eine
gute Lösung gefunden zu haben eine
Arztpraxis die der Notaufnahme
vorgeschaltet ist hier fällt die
Entscheidung wer tatsächlich ein Notfall
ist und wer ambulant behandelt werden
kann wir haben 4.300 Patienten und davon
gehen tatsächlich letztendlich nur 18
Prozent im Jahr in die Notaufnahme
dieser junge Mann etwa ist wegen
Verdachts auf Malaria hier er kommt
nicht in die Notaufnahme die nötigen
Untersuchungen macht die Ärztin gleich
selbst bei einer anderen Patientin lag
der Fall anders die Patientin habe ich
untersucht der hatte starkes starke
Bauchschmerzen
und die waren so stark dass ich sie in
die Chirurgie geschickt habe ein Modell
dass die Notaufnahmen entlastet ganz
ohne Strafgebühr
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius und
entwicklungsministerin Schulze sind zu
einem dreitägigen Besuch in die
krisengebeutete Sahel Region gereist
erste Station niga in der Hauptstadt
politische Gespräche und der Besuch von
Projekten des World food-programm im
Mittelpunkt in Niger sollen künftig 60
deutsche Soldatinnen und Soldaten
stationiert werden
islamistische Rebellen haben das
Dreiländereck Niger Mali Burkina der
Welt gemacht
tausende Flüchtlinge kommen ja für Jahr
in Italien an und die Behörden sind
damit zunehmend überfordert jetzt hat
die Regierung den Notstand beschlossen
dieses Jahr gelangten bereits mehr als
31.000 Flüchtlinge nach Italien viermal
mehr als im Vorjahreszeitraum die
meisten nehmen auf dem Weg nach Europa
die gefährlichen Routen übers zentrale
Mittelmeer mit dem Notstand sollen
Italiens betroffene Regionen nun
entlastet werden Annette hilsenbeck
berichtet sie haben die Fahrt über das
Mittelmeer geschafft heute am Mittag
erreichte dieses libysche Fischerboot
mit bis zu 700 Menschen an Bord die
Küste von Sizilien bereits am letzten
Wochenende waren tausende Migranten im
Süden Italiens angekommen nun hat die
Regierung den Notstand ausgerufen
der Notstand wir müssen den Regionen
helfen denn das System steht vor dem
Kollaps hoffentlich versteht Europa dass
wir nicht mehr viel Zeit zur Verfügung
haben
von der eu-gemeinschaft fühlt sich
Italien in der Migrationspolitik allein
gelassen und das Aufnahmelager auf der
Insel Lampedusa ist zurzeit erneut
komplett überfüllt nicht das erste Mal
in diesem Jahr die Ausrufung des
Notstandes gibt zunächst vor allem
finanzmittelfrei um hier und in den
anderen südlichen Regionen zu helfen
doch der Notstand ermöglicht auch
schneller Maßnahmen durchzuführen
Regelungen auszusetzen um etwa
Aufnahmelager errichten zu können
höherem Maße in Verfahren einzugreifen
und sie hat mehr Ressourcen um gegen
illegale Einwanderung vorzugehen etwa
wenn es darum geht weitere
abschiebezentren zu eröffnen
ein wichtiges Anliegen der rechten
Regierung Georgia melonis sie hatte
beschlossen mehr abschiebezentren zu
bauen um mehr Menschen abschieben zu
können auch das geht nun im Notstand
einfacher
sechs Monate soll der andauern derweil
entdecken auch jetzt Helfer und Behörden
immer wieder Boote die übers Meer kommen
der Luftangriff der Militär runter von
Myanmar auf ein Dorf sorgt weltweit für
Entsetzen du unverurteilten die Attacke
scharf die EU sprach von einer Gräueltat
die Militär herunter räumte ein für den
Angriff verantwortlich zu sein man habe
eine Veranstaltung der oppositionellen
volksverteidigungskräfte angegriffen so
wie ein Waffenlager lokale Medien
sprechen von bis zu 100 Toten darunter
auch Kinder
zur Wirtschaft Inflation Turbulenzen bei
Banken der Krieg in der Ukraine dazu
hohe Zinsen und steigende Verschuldung
der Internationale Währungsfonds waren
vor einer langen Krise der
Weltwirtschaft das globale Wachstum
werde sich verlangsamen von 3,4% im
vergangenen Jahr auf
2,8%. in Deutschland könnt ihr die
Wirtschaft sogar leicht schrumpfen
Isabel de la Vega mit den Einzelheiten
auf dem Frühjahrstreffen des IWF
herrscht wenig Aufbruchstimmung die
Energiepreise hohe Schuldenstände und
ein niedriges Wachstum die Prognose für
Deutschland minus 0,1% für 2023 wir
brauchen ein wie ich mal zum
Jahreswechsel genannt habe ein Wachstums
Pakets denn die deutsche
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit hat offensichtlich
gelitten unsere Produktivität ist nicht
da wo sie sein sollte wir haben auf der
anderen Seite aber auch große Potenziale
und Chancen die wir freisetzen können
und wollen auch der Zustand der
Weltwirtschaft stimmt skeptisch
wir treten in eine gefährliche Phase ein
in der das Wachstum niedrig ist die
Risiken im Finanz-
die Zentralbanken haben die Zinsen
erhöht höhere Zinsen aber bremsen die
Wirtschaft das ist der Preis für eine
erfolgreiche Inflationsbekämpfung
überraschend positiv fällt die Prognose
des IWF für Russland aus
0,7% Wirtschaftswachstum trotz des
Krieges und der Sanktionen
russland hat im letzten Jahr noch sehr
viel Öl und Gas exportieren können und
auch die Ausgaben für die
Rüstungsindustrie also die Ausgaben des
Krieges hatten einen positiven Effekt
auf die russische Konjunktur das war wie
ein großes Konjunkturprogramm es ist
Russland außerdem gelungen seine
Lieferketten besser als erwartet auf
andere Lieferanten umzustellen
beispielsweise aus China der Ukraine
Krieg bleibt ein großer
Unsicherheitsfaktor für die globale
Wirtschaft da sind sich die Experten des
IWF einig
und in den USA ist die Inflation
deutlich gesunken fragen wir nach bei
Sina meinitz Sina sind wir über dem Berg
oder ist das erstmal nur so ein
Hoffnungsschimmer also es handelt sich
wohl nur um einen Etappensieg aber
immerhin ist die Teuerungsrate für Waren
und Dienstleistungen in den USA im März
auf 5% gesunken im Februar lag sie noch
bei 6 %. das ist ein starker Rückgang
der auch am deutschen Aktienmarkt zu
einem deutlichen Kurssprung und diesem
Peak beim DAX geführt hat ebenso schnell
kehrte aber die Normalität zurück am
Ende ein Plus bei einem Stand von
15.704 Punkten die US-Notenbank Fett
feiert heute zwar diesen Rückgang der
Inflationsrate ihre etlichen
Zinserhöhungen wirken und Dämmen die
Teuerung ein über den Berg ist die
Wirtschaft damit aber noch nicht denn
die Kerninflation bei der Energie und
Lebensmittelpreise herausgerechnet
werden die bleibt nach wie vor hoch und
sie gilt auch als Alarmsignal weil sich
diese hohen Preise dann verfestigen
könnten die Kerninflation ist von
Februar bis März sogar leicht gestiegen
weitere Zinsschritte könnten also folgen
doch sie sind vor diesem Hintergrund der
Krise einzelner Banken nicht ohne
Nebenwirkungen und die würde auch
Deutschland führen vielen Dank
ziemlich genau 25 Jahre nach dem
Karfreitagsabkommen ist US-Präsident
beiden heute erst nach Nordirland und
dann in die Republik Irland gereist auch
eine persönliche Spurensuche beidens
Familie hat irische Wurzeln an einer
nordirischen Universität hielt beiden
eine Rede und appellierte den Frieden zu
wahren über den Besuch berichtet Heike
Petersen
wie zu Hause beiden auf Tour durch
Irland
Zwischenstopp in Dublin Zeit für Kinder
und ein paar kleine Geschichten aus
langem Politiker leben
die erste Hälfte des Tages im
nordirischen Belfast das war der
politische Teil beiden würdig das
Karfreitagsabkommen das Nordirland vor
25 Jahren Frieden brachte
[Applaus]
freitagsabkommen zeigt dass es Hoffnung
gibt tiefe Gräben zu überwinden es hilft
überall auf der Welt an Erneuerung und
Fortschritt fürs eigene Leben zu glauben
es erlaubte einer ganzen Generation in
Nordirland bessere Verbindungen
untereinander
dennoch Nordirland ist politisch
instabil das Parlament durch brexit
Streitigkeiten gelähmt würden die
beendet beiden deutet mehr Investitionen
von US-Firmen in Nordirland an
jetzt sieht es beiden in den Süden in
der Republik Irland nach Kalin Ford
Heimatort seiner Urahnen die Mitte des
19 Jahrhunderts nach Amerika
auswanderten den ihre stämmigen
US-Präsidenten verehren sie hier
geradezu als Vizepräsident war beiden
zuletzt 2016 hier
er hat damals versprochen als Präsident
wiederzukommen er hat Wort gehalten wir
sind sehr aufgeregt dass der Präsident
in unsere Gegend kommt weiter kann man
es nicht bringen
der Präsident vielleicht schon deutet an
noch mal antreten zu wollen
irisch-amerikanische Beziehungen zu
feiern das dürfte helfen
und jetzt schauen wir auf einen
Arbeitskampf und zwar auf einer
Autobahnraststätte in Südhessen dort
stehen laut Gewerkschaft mittlerweile
mehr als 60 Lastwagen weil ihre
osteuropäischen Fahrer ausstehenden Lohn
von ihren polnischen Arbeitgebern
einfordern das ganze wird ein
Schlaglicht auf die Arbeitsbedingungen
in der Branche über den Streik Susanna
rund 60 LKWs stehen auf der Raststätte
Gräfenhausen still weil die Fahrer von
ihrem polnischen Arbeitgeber seit vielen
Monaten kein Geld erhalten haben die
Streikenden kommen vor allem aus
Usbekistan und Georgien und sind froh
dass sie endlich Öffentlichkeit haben
wir werden so lange hier bleiben und
streiten bis wir unser Geld bekommen wir
wollen doch nur das was uns zusteht das
Geld für das wir gearbeitet haben keinen
Cent mehr
unterstützt werden die Streitenden von
mehreren Gewerkschaften und dem
Bundesverband Güter Kraftverkehr
Vorstandsprecher Dirk Engelhardt sieht
auch Deutschland in der Pflicht die
deutschen verlade die diese
Transportunternehmen einsetzen müssen in
die Pflicht genommen werden wir haben
lieferkettengesetz was entsprechend dann
auch überprüft werden muss auf der
anderen Seite muss Zoll und das
Bundesamt für Logistik und Mobilität und
die Landespolizei und sowas natürlich
auch kontrollieren so Eskalation kam es
letzten Freitag als der polnische
Arbeitgeber Mitarbeiter einer
Sicherheitsfirma auf die Raststätte
schickte begleitet von einem rechten
polnischen Sender wollten die Fahrer mit
Gewalt aus ihren Kabinen zerren der Chef
drohte ihn mit Kündigung und einer damit
drohenden Abschiebung aus der EU kein
Einzelfall so die Gewerkschaft was wir
schienen
auf europäischen Straßen auch um eine
Abschiebung zu verhindern unterschrieben
die Fahrer heute eine Petition an die
deutsche und polnische Regierung sie
wollen so lange streiken bis sie endlich
ihr Geld bekommen
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann hat
Eckpunkte für ein Gesetz gegen digitale
Gewalt vorgestellt wiederholte Hass
Drogen und Beleidigungen im Internet
sollen härter bestraft werden bis hin
zur Sperrung von Social Media konnten
wer in seinen Rechten verletzt werde
müsste sich vor Gericht effektiv dagegen
wehren können erklärte buschmann
textroboter mit künstliche Intelligenz
funktionieren so sie geben ein paar
Stichworte und Beschreibungen ein und
schon schreibt einem das Programm einen
vollständigen Text zum Beispiel auch
über einen bestimmten Menschen in diesem
Fall zieht sich der textroboter Infos
über die Person aus dem Netz
Chat GPT ist so ein textroboter eine
Klasse in Hamburg hat dazu ein
Experiment gemacht Sven Ricken berichtet
max ist ein Schüler der leider durch
seine Unpünktlichkeit auffällt obwohl
eine künstliche Intelligenz beschreibt
Oberstufen Schüler Max aber woher wusste
das Programm Chat GPT das mit der
Unpünktlichkeit aus dem Arbeitsauftrag
seiner Mitschüler die von dem System
einen Text wollten über den netten Max
der aber oft zu spät kommt für die Infos
die ich bekommen hat war die
Zusammenfassung schon ganz gut würde ich
sagen in ihrem Oberstufenkurs
beschäftigen sich die angehenden
Abiturienten mit Chat GPT das Programm
merkt sich alle Eingaben alle Antworten
und alle Reaktionen und damit kann es
die Wahrscheinlichkeit berechnen was der
Nutzer als nächstes wissen möchte ich
merke dass eine KI mir immer irgendwie
scheinbar ein kleines Stück voraus ist
und schon mal vorausahnen oder berechnen
kann was ich eigentlich angeblich will
oder vorhabe microsoft hat mit dieser
Technik gerade eine neue Plattform
vorgestellt die nutzt wie Chat GPT das
gesamte Wissen des Internets damit aber
auch alle dort öffentlich einsehbaren
persönlichen Daten richtige und falsche
freundliche und böse Kommentare ein
Datenschutzproblem habe ich da irgendein
Schutz der Gegend das z.B Falzen
Informationen von mir die im Netz
vorhanden sind weiter verbreitet werden
durch die KI weiter verwurstet und uns
auf ein anderes Level gehoben werden das
sind wichtige Fragen von Betroffenen
rechten die aus unserer Sicht völlig
ungeklärt sind sind
gpt-betreiber open ai ist bereits im
Gespräch mit den europäischen
Datenschützern schon jetzt lässt die KI
keine stigmatisierenden Aussagen zu so
wie am Ende bei Max es ist wichtig ihn
nicht einfach aufgrund seiner
Unpünktlichkeit zu verurteilen sondern
ihm die Gelegenheit zu geben sich zu
zeigen und zu beweisen dass er mehr zu
bieten hat am Ende nimmt die KI den
Schüler den Schutz auch das eine
simulierte menschliche Eigenschaft
und jetzt kommen wir zu den Menschen
zurück zum Sport zur Champions League da
kann man künstlich Intelligenz auch
nicht so richtig einsetzen Sven und es
war ein bitterer Abend gestern für die
Bayern oder definitiv Jana überraschend
deutlich verliert Bayern München das
Viertelfinale Hinspiel gegen ManCity und
braucht nun ein mittleres Fußballwunder
um doch noch weiter zu kommen Bayern
Trainer Thomas Tuchel wird später beim
Rückblick auf das Spiel die Tore lieber
beiseite lassen auf citys
Führungstreffer durch roadri Folge nach
der Pause einige Chancen im guten
Münchner Spiel aber auch Opa americanos
Fehler aus dem nach Flanke von Erling
Holland durch Bernardo silver das 2:0 in
der 70 Minute wird doch mit dem Resultat
hält sich Tuchel nicht lange auf ich
habe so viele gute Sachen gesehen dass
ich mich weiger das Ergebnis heute in
den Mittelpunkt zu stellen ich weigere
mich schlichtweg ich weiß es mag
blöd klingeln und dann ist vielleicht
wie sie sagen nicht Bayern like aber so
ist es heute für Mensch ist da steht der
30 Endstand er im Mittelpunkt beim
Rückspiel nächste Woche in München sind
sie damit klar favorisiert
[Applaus]
und alles zum Bayern Debakel und den
Champions League Duellen von heute um 23
Uhr im Sportstudio
100 Tage vor Beginn der WM haben
Deutschlands Fußballfrauen ihr Testspiel
gegen Brasilien verloren für Jennifer
maroshan war es trotzdem ein ganz
besonderer Abend nach 112 Länderspielen
ist Schluss Abschied von den
Teamkolleginnen natürlich ganz viel
emotionale Worte
wertschätzende Worte weil sie den
absolut ja höchsten Respekt verdient
eine verunsicherte Mannschaft von
Martina Forst Tecklenburg kassiert einen
frühen Gegentreffer tamirez nutzt die
defensiven Unstimmigkeiten nichts zu
sehen von Team D Brasilien
spielfreudiger und mit Glück in dieser
Szene zu zweit zu 0 Führung die erste
richtige Torchance der DFB-Auswahl in
der 92 Minute verwandelt dann Jule Brand
zum eins zu zwei Endstand ist zudem im
Juli muss sich die Mannschaft steigern
die deutschen Handball Frauen haben sich
für die Weltmeisterschaft qualifiziert
auch im zweiten Playoff Spiel gegen
griechenlandsauswahl gab es einen klaren
Erfolg diesmal 36 zu 20 Ende November
geht es dann zur WM nach Dänemark
Schweden und nach Norwegen
da fahren wir mit Jana oh ja gerne
schauen wir noch auf die Lottozahlen
diese wurden gezogen die Gewinnzahlen
lauten 27 28 33 34 44 Superzahl ist die
8 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
unbeständig bleibt beim Wetter mit neuen
Schauern mehr dazu gleich von essen
um 21:45 Uhr zum heute journal schönen
Abend noch
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja wechselhaft
geht es auch morgen weiter neue Schauer
bilden sich in der Kaltluft die von
Westen her reinzieht ja ansonsten an den
Alpen und vor allem im Alpenraum dann
weitere Schneefälle in der Nacht also
ganz im Süden an den Alpen Schnee
ansonsten hier noch Regen auch längere
Zeit Regen und Gewitter im Norden ziehen
allmählich nach Nordosten hinab und es
wird früher gehen trockener bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von 0 Grad im hessischen
Bergland und 7 Grad am mildesten ganz im
Osten Deutschlands morgen dann erst
einmal viel Sonne auch in den westlichen
Landes teil aber dann bilden sich hier
Schauer und im Osten ist es zunächst
auch verbreitet freundlich nach Süden
hin viele Wolken mit Schauern und
Gewittern an den alpenfeld weiterhin
Schnee bei höchsten Temperaturen von 6
bis 12 Grad in der Südhälfte ganz im
Norden ist es
deutlich milder teils 14 Grad ganz im
Westen die kommenden Tage am Freitag in
der Osthälfte viele Wolken im Westen
dagegen viel Sonnenschein weil 7 bis 15
Grad und auch die darauf folgenden Tage
am Wochenende recht wechselhaft ein
schöner Abend